new AI model named Sam from meta just
dropped it stands for Segment anything
model and is capable of outlining
objects in an image in just 50
milliseconds it was trained on a massive
data set of 1 billion image masks but
what makes it unique is that it's
promptable a user can provide
foregrounder background points a
bounding box or just freeform text to
determine which objects to segment this
is huge because it will make extracting
objects from images much easier and even
for lifting them into 3D in the near
future when we all have VR headsets
surgically attached to our faces this
Tech could quickly identify undesirable
objects like ugly faces then use
generative image models to beautify them
in real time or when walking down the
streets of San Francisco homeless people
could be easily erased from the
landscape thus making the world a better
place